einen schönen guten abend und willkommen
zu zdf heute live auf den tag genau vor
80 jahren also am 22 juni 1941 begann
der deutsche überfall auf die
sowjetunion kein anderes land im zweiten
weltkrieg musste eine derart hohe
opferzahl beklagen wie die sowjetunion
rund 27 millionen menschen verloren
insgesamt ihr leben davon rund 14
millionen zivilistinnen und zivilisten
in allen hat der bundespräsident hat
frank walter steinmeier heute mit einer
kranzniederlegung gedacht am
sowjetischen ehrenmal schönholzer heide
in berlin pankow und auch wir widmen
unseren streamen heute diesen gedenken
und auch dem aktuell deutsch russischen
verhältnis eure kommentare und fragen
wie immer gerne an dieser stelle an uns
wir sprechen gleich mit gregor gysi seit
vielen jahren bundestagsabgeordneter und
außenpolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion der linken nämlich und wir
sprechen mit dem bestseller autor
wladimir kaminer der zwar auf deutsch
schreibt aber in moskau geboren und
aufgewachsen ist zunächst aber
verdeutlicht und jonas post es nochmal
in kurzen worten die bedeutung des
heutigen datums und dazu muss er in der
geschichte sogar noch ein kleines stück
weiter zurückging dreiundzwanzigster
august 1939 der deutsche und der
sowjetische außenminister unterzeichnen
eine nicht angriffs vertrag zwischen
ihren beiden staaten in einem geheimen
zusatzprotokoll zu diesem sogenannten
hitler-stalin-pakt teilen die beiden
mächte polen und das gesamte östliche
mitteleuropa unter sich auf
diese absprache ermöglicht den deutschen
überfall auf polen am 1 september 1939
zwei tage später erklären großbritannien
und frankreich deutschland den krieg
erst nachdem deutsche truppen die
polnische regierung vertrieben hatten
marschiert auch die rote armee in polen
ein und besitzt den ostteil des landes
im juni und juli 1940 verleibt sich die
sowjetunion unter stalin die baltischen
staaten estland lettland und litauen 1
während deutschland in westeuropa krieg
führt nach dem deutschen sieg über
frankreich gibt hitler im juli 1940 den
befehl einen angriff auf die sowjetunion
zu planen
dieser angriff beginnt am 22 juni 1941
unter der bezeichnung unternehmen
barbarossa als ziel des krieges hatte
hitler die völlige zerschlagung der
sowjetunion ausgerufen
dafür hatte er seine truppen
aufgefordert besonders brutal vorzugehen
sie schrieben mit ihren gewehren und
riefen partizan und jagten uns aus dem
haus danach gingen wir hinunter zum bach
wo wir uns im gestrüpp verstecken sie
kündeten häuser und wir fanden das ganze
dorf nieder
einschließlich unseres hauses ich sah
unser haus trotz des grausamen vorgehens
der deutschen truppen scheitert der
feldzug im osten letztlich die
niederlage von stalingrad im winter 1942
43 markiert einen wendepunkt des kriegs
der für das deutsche reich schließlich
am 8 mai 1945 mit der kapitulation endet
also die klappe historische einordnung
wird heutigen datum und natürlich
hier und heute nur sehr unzureichend
wiedergegeben werden was es an grauen
und brutalität und gewalt bei diesem
feldzug gegeben hatte er letztlich einen
vernichtungsfeldzug war wenden wir uns
daher unseren gästen zu einem schönen
guten abend gregor gysi uns zugeschaltet
aus new york wo er dienstlich unterwegs
ist unter anderem auch den russischen
botschafter trifft und einen schönen
guten abend an wladimir kaminer uns
zugeschaltet aus kiew also sehr
international sind wir heute abend
aufgestellt herr gysi heute die
kranzniederlegung des bundespräsidenten
bereits vergangene woche seine rede bei
der eröffnung der ausstellung über
sowjetische kriegsgefangene
wie bewerten sie denn die aktuelle
berliner gibt den kultur ist sie
ausreichend na ja wir hatten ja
beantragt eine gedenkstunde im bundestag
durchzuführen
das hat der bundestagspräsident leider
abgelehnt so dass wir dann als fraktion
das selbstständig gemacht haben und ich
verstehe es ehrlich gesagt nicht weil er
geht es doch gar nicht um die politik
putin sondern diese gedenkstunde sind
wir einfach der belorussischen
ukrainischen und selbstverständlich vor
allem auch der russischen bevölkerung
gegenüber schuldig deshalb hätte ich es
gut gefunden wenn wir das gemacht hätten
aber die kanzlerin hat sich geäußert der
bundespräsident hat sich geäußert das
finde ich natürlich richtig und
notwendig für camille navis ihrer
einschätzung dazu
es ist sehr laut aber ich habe nochmal
nach ihrer einschätzung gefragt wie
haben sie die gedenkkultur in
deutschland in berlin im politischen
berlin der letzten tage wahrgenommen
aus meiner sicht erinnert sich das land
also deutschland erinnert sich gut an
die geschehnisse von damals und das
sieht man auch an der heutigen situation
haben die deutschen aus ihrer niederlage
eigentlich viel mehr gelernt was ihnen
heute hilft sie weiterbringt als meine
landsleute als als russland aus seiner
musik zur gedenkkultur in russland würde
ich sie gerne nachher auch noch einmal
befragen aber zunächst noch einmal würde
ich in deutschland bleiben wollen es gab
ja deutliche kritik von seiten anderer
ehemaliger sowjet nationen am ort der
gewählt wurde
für die ausstellungseröffnung und für
die rede des bundespräsidenten am
vergangenen freitag dies sei ein affront
sagte zum beispiel der ukrainische
botschafter die udssr dürfe nicht mit
russland gleichgesetzt werden weil eben
das deutsch russische museum ausgewählt
wurde
auch sieben andere staaten haben ihre
teilnahme abgesagt herr gysi wie haben
sie das empfunden
diese kritik sehe ich verstehe natürlich
die kritik der anderen länder weil ja
alle beteiligt waren an dem krieg und
damit auch am sieg aber man kommt
natürlich nicht umhin einzuräumen dass
die größte zahl der opfer aus russland
kam und dass die russen auch an den sieg
am größten
konsequentesten beteiligt waren das darf
man dabei nicht vergessen aber
selbstverständlich muss man auf die
vielen opfer sehen in der ukraine
die alu guss und in den anderen staaten
der ehemaligen sowjetunion
herr kaminer haben sie die kritik der
anderen ehemaligen sowjetrepubliken
verstehen können nachvollziehen können
natürlich kann ich das nachvollziehen
ich bin gerade selbst in kiel und in
einer stadt die vollkommen die welt
bombardiert wurde
die ersten burg und fielen am 22 juni
1941 in 45 hier auf die waschstraßen
deswegen halte diese stadt auch ihre
ganze europäische architektur verloren
und die touristen auch unter anderem
auch aus deutschland die nach dem krieg
herkamen und sagt dann auch endlich
sehen sie mal was anders diese
statistischen bauten ist doch viel
interessanter als die europäische
architektur die haben wir ja sonst wo
überall schon gesehen
ich finde es falsch wenn in der heutigen
politischen diskussion die erinnerung an
den damaligen krieg missbraucht wird
wir sehen ständig diese versuche seitens
weißrussland und seit es auch der dem
publikum natürlich weil man muss klar
trennen das was heute in europa
geschieht was auch gefährlich ist auch
für die zukunft europäischen union
gefährlich jetzt ist eine andere
geschichte
sie hat mit dem damaligen krieg wenig zu
tun
ja damals sind millionen gestorben
ukrainer illya rosen juden und russen
haben alle gemeinsam gegen den
faschismus
dass irgendwas dabei nichts an der
tatsache dass alle diese ehemaligen
sowjetischen republiken heute angst
haben nicht vor deutschlands und nicht
eu sondern vor ihrem rutschung nachbar
und darüber muss man auch sich im klaren
sein
ja das bringt jetzt wieder die aktuelle
politik wie gesagt darauf kommen wir
dann gleich noch zu sprechen herr gysi
niemand das sagt der bundespräsident am
freitag niemand hatte in diesem krieg
mehr opfer zu beklagen als die völker
der damaligen sowjetunion
und doch sind diese millionen nicht so
tief in unser kollektives gedächtnis
eingebrannt wie ihr leid und unsere
verantwortung es fordern gesagt dass
bundespräsident steinmeier am freitag
würden sie ihm zustimmen und wenn ja was
glauben sie warum ist das so
ja ich stimme mit dem bundespräsidenten
zu aber weiter bei ein unterschied hin
es sieht im osten deutschlands etwas
anders aus als im westen deutschlands
das hat natürlich auch mit dem kalten
krieg zu tun die drei westlichen
besatzungsmächte und die sowjetunion
standen sicher dann sehr sehr kritisch
und gegnerische gegenüber und das hat
natürlich auf die bevölkerung in der
bundesrepublik geprägt in der ddr war es
anders obwohl es auch dort viele mit
einer er sage ich mal an die
sowjetischen haltung gab aber das
änderte sich mit gorbatschow und über
roberts änderte sich das
interessanterweise dann auch nach der
einheit so dass wir heute wenn wir
umfragen machen
im osten und im westen zb zur frage der
sanktion aber eben auch zur zum sieg der
sowjetunion und der anderen länder über
deutschland im zweiten weltkrieg sehr
unterschiedliche ergebnisse haben und
insofern hat herr steinmeier recht aber
er hätte differenzieren müssen was hat
natürlich nicht gemacht hat zwischen der
öffentlichen und der westlichen
bevölkerung weil es dort im nennenswerte
unterschiede in der beurteilung sowohl
der geschichte als auch der heutigen
situation
das ist schwierigkeiten gibt was das
gedenken an das geschehen während des
krieges angeht in der sowjetunion aber
auch was den blick richtung osten
generell angeht das sieht übrigens auch
die historikerin corinna chur korolew so
und wir hören mal was sie zu sagen hat
wegschauen definitiv zu wenig in den
osten also das interesse an osteuropa
insgesamt ist insgesamt es nicht groß
und ist das ist bedauerlich das hat auch
was mit dem kalten krieg zu tun dass
eben für großteil der europäer osteuropa
schwer zugänglich war
und diese grenze dieser eiserne fonds
bei vielen im kopf geblieben ist also
die angst der schritt nach russland zu
fahren oder in die ukraine zu fahren ist
viel viel größer als richtung westen zu
fahren obwohl die entfernung nicht
weiter sind
das klingt so als gäbe es immer noch so
eine art eisernen vorhang in den köpfen
der leute im westen zumindest wie
erleben sie beide das vielleicht fange
ich mal mit herrn kamine an ist das eine
akkurate beschreibung sehen sie das auch
so
nein überhaupt nicht es gibt keinen
eisernen vorangehen den köpfen der der
ostdeutschen
diese menschen haben
sowjetische armee als durchaus als
freundlicher zurückhaltung dem besagter
erleben und sie wollen ihre deutsch
sowjetische freundschaft die erinnerung
daran
die halten als teil ihres sozialisierung
pass ist teil ihrer kindheit wenn sie so
wollen ein teil ihrer tiere ihrer kultur
dass sie dabei jetzt bestimmte
vorkommnisse der aktuellen russischen
politik ausblenden und sagen egal was
die russen tun die bleiben trotzdem
freunde
das kann man den menschen und jetzt
nicht als schuld in die schuhe schieben
und er letzten endes haben sie auch
recht
ich meine die regierung gehen die kommen
und gehen und das land bleibt russland
ist ein großes kreatives und vor allem
europäisches land das vielleicht heute
eine dunkle stunde hat aber seinen weg
in die europäische gemeinschaft finden
wird da kann man ja sie haben denken
wenn wir würden sie heute bitte wenden
sie heute an bestimmte fehler der
russischen führung kritisieren und
ausruhen und müssen wir tun
ich verstehe herr kaminer sie haben
natürlich selbst russische wurzeln sind
jetzt gerade in kiew unterwegs feiern
dort mit ihrer frau die es weit ich weiß
auch aus russland kommt also für sie
trifft das für möglich nicht so zu aber
herr gysi wie erleben sie das jetzt bei
ihren deutschen mitbürgern herr kaminer
das natürlich auch deutsch aber wie
gesagt mit einem anderen hintergrund
wie erleben sie das erkennen sie so eine
art eisernen vorhang noch denn ich denke
man kann schon sagen dass zumindest die
reisetätigkeit oder vielleicht auch das
interesse an den östlichen
nachbarländern wohl etwas geringer sein
dürfte als an den westlichen also die
historikerin hat recht ob man nun von
einem eisernen vorhang sprechen soll
oder nicht das ist noch eine andere
frage aber im kern hat sie recht
interesse für osteuropa ist in allen
westlichen ländern viel zu gering aber
wieder haben wir in deutschland den
unterschied hier wieder zwischen den
neuen und den alten bundesländern weil
die menschen in den alten bundesländern
eben anders aufgewachsen sind als die in
den neuen bundesländern
deshalb gibt es dort auch mehr reisen
richtung osten als aus der früheren
alten bundesrepublik auch dass es wieder
bemerkenswert und das mussten wir
natürlich irgendwann überwinden weil wir
müssen ja begreifen europa als ganzes
und da hat er recht
auch die ukraine gehört zu europa auf
belarus gehört zu europa und auch
russland gehört zu europa und das dürfen
wir nie vergessen wir sprechen immer von
europa nur die europäische union
aber europa ist größer als der
europäische union vielleicht ein maler
der appell an dieser stelle an der
unsere zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
userinnen und user gerne mitzumachen ich
habe noch nicht viele kommentare und
fragen aber gerne immer her damit damit
wir sie an unsere beiden gäste dann auch
weiterleiten können ich würde gerne
weitermachen mit jörg [ __ ] ist der
direktor des deutsch russischen museums
und er sagt in vielen osteuropäischen
ländern sei der zweite weltkrieg noch
wesentlich präsenter als in deutschland
dort sei er gegenwärtig in deutschland
sei er geschichte wenn das stimmt was
sollte aus dieser analyse deutschland
folgen und vielleicht auch für das
verhältnis der deutschen zu den
osteuropäischen nachbarn herr gysi
also wahrscheinlich sind die familien
anders betroffen gewesen in deutschland
war der umgang mit dem zweiten weltkrieg
und dem naziregime natürlich viel
schwieriger weil man sich ja fragen muss
welchen anteil hat meine familie an den
verbrechen die begangen worden sind
sie wissen ja in der ddr fand sehr
schnell und frühzeitig nach 45 eine
aufarbeitung dieser geschichte statt
allerdings mit einem mangel die
regierung bestand ja tatsächlich aus
antifaschisten und deshalb waren sie
gezwungen weil sie in der mehrheit
repräsentieren wollten die ganze
bevölkerung der antifaschistische zu
erklären was natürlich gar nicht stimmen
konnte und in der bundesrepublik ist man
den weg gegangen erst mal diese
geschichte auszublenden darüber
möglichst nicht zu reden keine pläne
darüber zu drehen etc
bis dann die jugend 68 protestiert hat
und das war irgendwie spannendste wahl
glaube ich in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik zwischen kiesinger kurt
georg kiesinger auf der einen seite und
willy brandt auf der anderen seite also
einer war mitglied der nsdap bei
abteilungsleiter in einem nazi
ministerium der andere trat unter seinem
decknamen nämlich brand an den er
bekommen hat im kampf gegen die nazis
auch bei den norwegischen streitkräften
etc
und dieses gegenüber das war eine so
spannende kulturelle politische
auseinandersetzung in der bundesrepublik
und es hat im knapp willy brandt für
sich entschieden und für die ein wahrer
eben der vaterlandsverräter und für die
acht ein wahrer der retter des
vaterlandes ein hochinteressanter
auseinandersetzung und deshalb gehen wir
in deutschland anders damit um ist das
für uns viel historisches kommt noch
etwas hinzu
was ganz einfaches alle bilder oder fast
alle bilder aus der nazizeit sind
schwarz-weiß sind nicht in farbe und für
die jungen ist die gegenwart immer ein
farbe und vergangenheit ist schwarz-weiß
und da unterscheiden sie dann auch kaum
noch in den zeiten die sind sehr
unterschiedlich natürlich waren weiß ich
weiß kaiserzeit weimarer republik
nazi-diktatur cetera also umso wichtiger
das gedächtnis und das gedenken am leben
zu erhalten auch in schwarz weiß herr
kaminer seitens vorhin schon angedeutet
die gedenkkultur in russland vielleicht
auch in anderen osteuropäischen staaten
ist eine andere als in deutschland wie
würden sie die gedenkkultur
beispielsweise in russland beschreiben
da vor allem die aufarbeitung des
krieges war eine ganz andere
für uns stand es fest wir waren einfach
die sieger
sie haben und im alleingang übrigens
fast ohne hilfe von briten amerikaner
oder franzosen einen deutschen pass
und wir haben so zu lernen das befreit
die damals ganz freiwillig einfach aus
dem gefühl der solidarität mit uns sicht
wurde im sozialistischen weg entschieden
haben und so entstand diese große
sozialistische gilt nach dem krieg
entwickelt die halbe welt war
das war unsere aufarbeitung das was ich
aus deutschland kenne also ich hab
ziemlich als sich dann als meine kinder
hier zum gymnasium gingen und ich
erfahren musste dass alle schulklassen
da er so ins kz gebracht werden als eine
art geschichtsunterricht mussten sich
die menschen ansehen junge menschen
ansehen was ihre vorväter was ihre
vorfahren eingerichtet habe das ist da
geben sie mir glaube ich recht eine ganz
andere art der aufarbeitung der
geschichte ja aber keine kritikwürdige
da verstehe ich schon richtig dass
findet ihre zustimmung dass das so
passiert in deutschland oder naja ich
finde dass diese schande jeder lage hat
deutschland viel mehr gebracht politisch
ökonomisch menschlich einfach im geiste
hat dass diese diese hat diese
niederlage
das land weiter getragen und das was wir
heute an deutschland lieben und schätzen
haben wir auch diese niederlage zu
verdanken
ich würde gerne auch in meiner einher
heute also der also mehr großzügigkeit
der welt gegenüber sehen diese absurde
aggressive haltung also noch nie
hatte russland so wenig freunde auf der
welt wie heute nicht mal die nicht mal
die sowjetunion eigentlich herr gysi sie
wollten ja ich würde gerne handys ich
das wort entschuldigung aus europa und
niemand ja ich wünsche der punkt ist
rübergekommen herr kaminer herr gysi
man darf eines nicht vergessen das wurde
ja immer als tag der niederlage
empfunden der 8 mai 1945 als das
deutsche reich oder das dritte reich
seine bedingungslose kapitulation
unterzeichnet und erst richard von
weizsäcker also sehr viel später hat das
erste mal gesagt es war ein tag der
befreiung auch das soll zum volk ist
deshalb kann ich herrn kaminer nicht
zustimmen dass wir das ist richtig
aufgearbeitet haben im unterschied zu
den anderen völkern
nein nein wir hatten da schon
beachtliche schwierigkeiten aber eins
ist natürlich war mit einer niederlage
umzugehen ist schwerer als mit einem
sieg das stimmt nur die niederlage hat
deutschland ja selber provoziert indem
es eben den zweiten weltkrieg begonnen
hat
und dann kam er noch hinzu dass ich sage
mal so deutschland hat sich in den
zweiten weltkrieg immer verlieren müssen
es gab keinen anderen ausgang aber als
der zwei konten krieg dazu kann man also
auf die sowjetunion überführt das war
natürlich auch ein großer fehler noch
nie hat einer nation russland im krieg
besiegt das sollte man also nicht
versuchen und es geht auch bei der
sowjetunion nicht abgesehen davon dass
das alles völlig inhuman und
verbrecherisch war
aber ich sage das nur deshalb weil wir
schon schwierigkeiten hatten im umgang
mit der geschichte aber im
den letzten jahren tatsächlich seit der
rede von richard von weizsäcker hat doch
die erkenntnis zugenommen dass es doch
ein tag der befreiung war und nicht ein
tag der niederlage aber das dauerte
seine zeit ist das begriffen wurde ja
das würde aber schon den bogen spannen
sozusagen auch zur gegenwart denn man
könnte jetzt auch sagen dass so ein
historisches datum ja auch die chance
bietet das gegenwärtige verhältnis zu
reflektieren vielleicht noch mal ein
sicher gysi die frage ist mitglied der
deutsch russischen parlamentariergruppe
wie ist es aktuell ihrer meinung nach um
das deutsch russische verhältnis
bestellt das ist natürlich ein weites
feld aber wenn sie es mal grob
skizzieren aus ihrer sicht also das
verhältnis ist gott ein schlechtes
vollzeit und das muss sich wieder ändern
nun ist es natürlich so herr kaminer
steht ja auch putin sehr kritisch
gegenüber damit habe ich auch keine
schwierigkeiten aber ich habe putin 2000
einzelnen bundestag erlebt als er die
zusammenarbeit auf allen gebieten
angeboten hat und der westen hat sich zu
arrogant verhalten er dachte das sei
nicht nötig obama hat ja auch gesagt das
ist bloß eine regionalmacht etc
dabei ist russland natürlich eine
atomare weltmacht und ständiges mitglied
mit vetorecht im sicherheitsrat der uno
es kommt bei mir noch eine apa und hinzu
ich komme aus der ddr
ich kannte die zeit der hallstein
doktrin also wo die bundesrepublik sagte
wenn ein land diplomatische beziehungen
zur ddr herstellt werden die
diplomatischen beziehungen zur
bundesrepublik abgebrochen
es herrscht wirklich ganz schlimmer
kalter krieg zwischen diesen beiden
deutschen staaten und nach dem mauerbau
hat dann willy brandt die politik
verändert weil sie plötzlich gesehen
haben man kann ja für bürgerinnen und
bürger der ddr aber auch der
bundesrepublik nichts erreichen wenn man
nicht mit der regierung redet er nannte
diese politik wandel durch annäherung
und ich beim ein anhänger
dieser politik und möchte dass wir bei
russland wieder wandel durch annäherung
machen natürlich wird können die
sanktionen noch verdoppeln und
verdreifachen
und natürlich gibt es sehr kritische
umständen der politik russland die hat
sich ja auch geändert da das angebot
2001 sich angenommen wurde
aber dann blockt er sich immer weiter ab
uns gegenüber es wird keine
humanistischen liebsten geben und ich
weiß von der ddr wie sich das verändert
hat nach dem besuch von willy brandt und
als es dann so eine art diplomat ischer
beziehung gab die größte amnestie in der
geschichte der ddr politische gefangene
wurden bei bestimmten anlässen
rausgelassen plötzlich konnten die leute
auch in dringenden
familienangelegenheiten in den westen
reisen nicht nur die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die dienstreisenden sondern
auch in solchen angelegenheiten
mit andern worten ich bin dafür dass wir
ein konstruktives verhältnis herstellen
um eben auch dann etwas zu erreichen um
putin und andere zu überzeugen dass sie
zumindest schrittweise eine andere
politik machen müssen
wandel durch annäherung die sanktionen
haben nichts gebracht er schottet sich
immer mehr ab er machte ja auch was er
will und genau das geht nicht ein
bisschen hoffnung habe ich jetzt seit
dem treffen gut den beiden dass da
vielleicht doch ein konstruktives
verhältnis entsteht was dann auch
wiederum die russische politik nach
innen und nach außen verändern könnte
herr kaminer hat ihnen zu stimmen
zugelegt sozusagen wie bewerten sie das
gegenwärtige verhältnis zwischen
deutschland und russland sie haben sich
in der vergangenheit oft sehr putin
kritisch geäußert aber während sie auch
für eine wiederauflage des prinzips
wandel durch annäherung
also gebe ich ja diese absolut recht die
sanktionen gegen ein solches großes land
kann und nichts bringen
sie müssen ein gespräch führen aber ich
glaube zum teil sind ja alle
ich kenne niemanden der gegen ein
konstruktives gespräch mit russland wäre
ich frage mich und ja diese und uns
allen warum klappte dieses gespräch
nicht reden wir mit falschen kabul sind
die argumente nicht deutlich genug also
ich glaube dieses gespräch das unbedingt
geführt werden muss braucht einfach ein
neues vokabular und neue worte eine
klare ansage
das ist das was fehlt wenn ich auf die
europäische politik sein leiden die das
nein oder ja es wird der kamin
ausstellung im grunde genommen nichts
herr gysi hatten sie da noch eine kurze
rede
also ist es so der außenminister als er
berufen wurde war einer seiner ersten
sätze wie heute härter werden
in einer seiner ersten sätze
weil sie haben das wort ja wohl also ja
gut seiner ersten sätzen börsen härter
wir hätten zu russland das ergebnis
waren das dann nach moskau fuhr vom
außenminister empfangen wurde und putin
sein empfang ablehnte bis dahin war
jeder außenminister auch von putin oder
dem vorgänger empfangen worden
das waren sich jedenfalls wenn man
russland sagt man wird härter dann
locken die sich eben ab und die eu hat
ja viele sanktionen beschlossen und
deshalb unterstützt er jetzt ja das
stimmt
dazu erzählte ich ihnen auch gleich
weist aber ich will nur auf folgendes
hin aus die sanktionen die gegen
russland beschlossen worden und viele
fordern härtere sanktionen
das verletzt auch den stolz der
russinnen und russen
und das ergebnis ist dass sie dann sich
immer mehr ab glocken auch gegenüber der
eu auch gegenüber deutschland deshalb
sage ich wir müssen ein konstruktives
verhältnis aufbauen schritt für schritt
die sanktion abbauen und russland muss
schritt für schritt die politik ändern
sagt mal ein beispiel die unterstützten
rechte kräfte die gegen die eu sind weil
eben die eu gegen sanktionen
geschlossenheit natürlich würde ich
fordern dass die unterstützung der
rechten kräfte aufhören muss aber dazu
muss ich ja auch schritte anbieten also
das ist ja immer eine frage der
gegenseitigkeit und ich wünsche mir aus
geostrategischen gründen ein
konstruktives verhältnis zu russland zu
china und wenn ich noch einen sagen darf
denn sich mal vor wir machen sanktionen
immer schärfer gegen china und russland
dann zwingen wir die ja zu einem bündnis
wissen sie was das für ein machtfaktor
china ist russland ökonomisch weit
überlegen
russland ist china noch militärisch
ich weiß nicht ob das klug ist beide
länder so zu behandeln dass man sie zu
einem engen bündnis zwingen also ich bin
da noch was und ich habe das hier auch
washington und new york angesagt und es
ist nicht so dass ich nur ablehnende
reaktionen darauf verfahren herr gysi da
würde ich gerne nach haken denn also im
prinzip haben sie die frage schon fast
beantwortet denn harbort schreibt uns
über youtube sollte man etwas gegen die
china russland beziehungen machen und
russland mehr an uns binden
das ist das was sie gerade vor
jetzt herrscht ein bisschen
durcheinander
davon dass hier gerade so ein track wird
aber jetzt ja verstehen sie es erkennen
ja immer mehr leute wir brauchen deshalb
sage ich wir brauchen ein konstruktives
verhältnis sowohl zu russland als auch
zu china wenn wir die zu einem so engen
bündnis zwingen dann bezahlen wir das
alle teuer
das können wir uns gar nicht leisten
deshalb und wissen wir die mehrheit der
staaten ist nicht demokratisch wir tun
also das ist ja ein irrtum
die mehrheit der staaten ist der
haltepunkt nur ihre und das spiegelt
sich auch in der uno wie das tut mir
immer nicht vergessen und deshalb müssen
wir die länder nehmen wie sie sind das
heißt auch nicht unkritisch zu sein
sondern das heißt nur ein konstruktives
verhältnis aufzubauen um auch mal was zu
erreichen
und ich sage nochmal ich da ich die ddr
erlebt habe ich habe diesen unterschied
erlebt wie sich die ddr veränderte
nachdem es normale beziehungen oder
normalere sammer so beziehungen zur
bundesrepublik deutschland gab die sohn
verhältnis brauchen ja auch gegenüber
russland und auch gegenüber china
und zwar in unserem interesse natürlich
auch im interesse der anderen aber auch
in unserem interesse
bedauerlicherweise haben wir gerade den
kontakt zu herrn camina in kiew verloren
aber eine frage hätte ich noch von love
supreme an sie herr gysi fänden sie es
denn gut wenn russland der eu beitreten
würde mal unabhängig davon wie
realistisch das ist ja das ist überhaupt
nicht überhaupt nicht realistisch ich
sag auch ganz offen
dass wir die osteuropäischen länder eine
idee zu früh aufgenommen haben in die eu
ich finde auch bei der nato aber ich
jetzt nur eu obwohl wir bestimmte
entwicklungen gar nicht abgewartet haben
was wir jetzt feststellen können in
rumänien bulgarien
es hätte noch etwas zeit bedürfe
natürlich ist russland noch gar nicht
reif für die die frage ist nur wollen
wir es dass russland so wird das auch
ein wichtiger bestandteil der
europäischen union wird oder wollen wir
es nicht ich will es aber ich sage noch
ist es nicht soweit ganz klar und wahr
herr gysi vielen dank für diese antwort
herr kam ja ich glaube sie können mich
jetzt wieder hören aber im grunde kann
ich die zeit da wir auch relativ weit
vorangeschritten sind nur dazu nutzen
mich bei ihnen beiden zu bedanken her
kamen dann noch mal im kia vielen dank
für ihre antworten und einschätzungen
und natürlich auch nochmal an herrn gysi
in new york fielen dank toll dass das
überhaupt geklappt hat heute danke und
natürlich auch für euch und ihnen vielen
dank fürs zuschauen und für die fragen
von denen wir immerhin noch zwei mit
rein nehmen konnten
euch allen einen schönen abend und bis
zum nächsten live stream